- All right, let's cap
things off with something
trending on social,
sure to make you smile.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
All right y'all may
remember Becca Stevens,
we've had her on this show
a few times over the years.
She's the founder of Thistle Farms,
the worldwide organization
helps women who've been
victims of abuse or sex trafficking
by giving them two years of
free housing and support.
It's a wonderful organization.
After that, the women are
encouraged to reach back
and help the newer women
in the program succeed.
Becca just put out a new book
called Practically Divine,
and it's all about finding
love and beauty and
everything that surrounds
us, which is so important.
We have Becca on the line right now.
What's up Becca?
Nice to see you.
- It's so good to see you. Thank you.
- I'm so excited. So where
are you calling from?
- I am in Oaxaca, Mexico.
I am meeting some amazing
new women who are gonna be
partners with us.
They're making beautiful clay things.
It is a great gift to be
here and meet new heroes
of my life.
- Oh that's so cool. Well,
congratulations on the book.
Can you tell us more about it?
- Yeah. Practically Divine is all about
gleaning from the last
25 years of this work
with some heroic women
mixed in with some good old
southern storytelling.
I think Practically Divine
is about thinking about
the imperfect perfect and
how it is that you and I
don't have to wait to
see diamonds to think
there's something beautiful and valuable
while we're walking along the trail,
we can appreciate the courts
and everything we see.
- I love that.
That's a very beautiful mentality.
So your late mother plays an
important role in this book,
right?
- Yeah. My mom, who was a
widow at 35, raising five kids,
working daycare, she was probably the most
practically divine person I know.
She just made everything about
an opportunity to see something good
that we can make it for
ourselves, that we can get past
this place by being where
we are, seeing the past
and dreaming about a better future.
And so I dedicated the book
to all four of my siblings,
who are living the legacy through
story, through their work,
through their children.
And we all started remembering
all her old sayings that
were like these beautiful
breadcrumbs along the way.
And so each chapter's like
one of her famous sayings
that we carry with us.
One of them is, you know,
three moves are as good as a fire,
which means let stuff go when you need to
don't drag it around.
Just remember most of
the stuff is dust anyway.
- Oh God, that's a really
great way to look at things.
That's an amazing, an
amazing thing to talk about.
That's great. So everybody,
you can pick up Becca's book
online and at most retailers.
Thank you so much, Becca,
for joining us again.
We love you here.
- [Becca] Love you.
- I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all girl,
our season-long partner, Pilot pen,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
wants to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you, Ma'am.
So they're gonna be using
their G2 gel ink pen to write
Thistle Farms a check
for a thousand dollars.
(audience and Becca cheering)
- Yeah.
All right. It's always
good to see you, Becca.